vamos a resolver este problema nos dan
la información de que hay es igual a 12
entonces de aquí para acá es igual a 12
nos dice también que ese es igual a 18
que s es igual a 18 y además tenemos más
información aquí en el diagrama tenemos
que a ese es un ángulo recto tenemos que
a de hebe y cf son medianas y eso lo
podemos ver porque los puntos a donde
llegan dividen en dos segmentos de igual
longitud a b igual abc se de igual a d e
y f igual a efe a entonces por eso son
medianas y tenemos aquí el punto g que
es el punto de intersección de las
medianas y por lo tanto el centro del
triángulo y además a este punto h que
está un poco raro pero al parecer es la
proyección de g sobre el lado
bueno con toda esa información que nos
dan nos piden determinar algunas cosas
empiezan diciéndonos que encontremos el
área del triángulo b g c entonces déjame
marcar el área que nos interesa sería
igual a esta área naranja de por acá
entonces queremos determinar esa área
pero eso va a ser más o menos sencillo
porque si te das cuenta este triángulo
es uno de los seis triángulos en los que
queda dividido a ese al trazar las
medianas y como ya vimos en un vídeo
anterior
todos esos triángulos tienen la misma
área y entonces cada uno de esos
triángulos va a tener un sexto del área
total del triángulo vale entonces vamos
a empezar calculando el área total del
triángulo entonces déjame poner aquí el
área del triángulo a ese a ese es igual
a y ésta está fácil porque es triángulo
rectángulo y tenemos la base y la altura
entonces es igual a un medio de la base
que es 18 por la altura que es igual a
esto de aquí es igual a un medio por 18
es 9 y 9 por 12 108 ok entonces el área
del triángulo s es igual a 108 y con eso
podemos encontrar el área del triángulo
wgc porque es una sexta parte entonces
tenemos el área del triángulo b g b g c
esa de ahí es igual a
sexto del área del triángulo a s el área
del triángulo a s y por lo tanto es
igual a un sexto de 108 que es igual a
un sexto de 108 me parece que es igual a
18 eso tiene sentido sí claro porque
porque de hecho a ese también es 6 por
18 entonces si dividimos entre 6 quedan
18 bueno entonces ya tenemos el área del
triángulo bgs esta de aquí está de aquí
es igual a 18 déjame ponerlo por acá y
de hecho ya tenemos el área de un montón
de triángulos verdad tenemos que estar
acá también es 18 estas 18 esta es 18
esto es 18 y también el de fg es 18 vale
todo el triángulo fg tiene área 18 pero
no lo voy a poner para que nos encima
mucho bueno entonces ya tenemos la
primera pregunta vamos a la segunda
queremos determinar la longitud de aje
de aje pero eso justo en la distancia
del vértice hacia el centro y de y eso
ya también sabemos cómo calcularlo
ya sabemos que esa distancia esa
distancia es 2
de la distancia total hasta el punto
medio entonces es dos tercios de la
longitud de la mediana
así que si logramos encontrar la
longitud de la mediana pues ya vamos a
estar muy cerca de encontrar a g vale y
para encontrar la longitud de la mediana
nos vamos a dar cuenta que es la
hipotenusa del triángulo rectángulo a d
y en el triángulo at tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos uno de los catetos mide 12 y
el otro de los catetos mide la mitad de
18 es decir mide 9 déjame ponerle por
aquí que mide 9 muy bien entonces vamos
a aplicar el teorema de pitágoras en el
triángulo ade
y con eso tenemos que ade al cuadrado es
igual a 9 al cuadrado más 12 al cuadrado
9 al cuadrado es 81 12 al cuadrado de
144 y por lo tanto a d al cuadrado es
igual a 225 y así tenemos que aden adde
es igual a la raíz de 225 que bueno a lo
mejor no te las cepas pero la puedes
calcular y queda
15 vale entonces a d es igual a 15 y ojo
estamos usando la raíz positiva porque
no tiene sentido utilizar la raíz
negativa en un problema de distancias
bueno entonces ade es igual a 15 a d es
igual a 15 y así a g ag que era lo que
nos interesaba
ag es igual a dos tercios de a de dos
tercios de ade porque sabemos que el
centro le queda a dos tercios de la
distancia del vértice al punto medio y
entonces esto es igual a dos tercios de
15 15 entre 13 es el 5 por 2 es y es
entonces es igual a 10 así tenemos que
aje es igual a 10 lo voy a apuntar por
acá y lo voy a poner aquí arriba con
color verde sale entonces ag es igual a
10 y finalmente nos piden determinar el
área del triángulo fh f g h entonces
sería determinar esta área que estoy
pintando en blanco bueno pues para
determinar el área de un triángulo y
este pues basta conocer su base y su
altura entonces vamos a encontrar
efe h vamos a encontrar fh y gh g h y
hay varias formas de encontrar
cualquiera de los dos
déjame empezar con gh vamos a hacer un
truco y vamos a pensar a gh como altura
del triángulo
efe g saleh entonces mira vamos a
calcular el área del triángulo fg y el
área del triángulo fg
es igual a un medio un medio de la base
que sería efe pero nosotros ya sabemos
que f es la mitad de 12 vale entonces
aquí sería 6 entonces el área del fg es
un medio de 6 x la altura que justo es
gh x g h pero nosotros también sabemos
el área de fg porque justo es uno de los
seis triangulitos que quedan cuando
trazamos las tres medianas entonces el
área de fg es igual a 18
esto de aquí es aquí igual a 18
y por lo tanto nos queda lo siguiente
nos queda que 1818 es igual a 3 x gh gh
y dividiendo entre 3 de ambos lados nos
queda que gh gh es igual a 6 vale
entonces con eso ya tenemos tenemos la
longitud de gh y voy a poner aquí que es
6 muy bien pero también necesitamos la
de fh antes de pasar a la de fh déjame
contarte que había otra forma de
obtenerla de gh observa que los
triángulos a hg y a efe parecen ser
semejantes porque tienen el ángulo recto
y el ángulo de acá bueno de hecho esa es
la prueba verdad entonces sus lados
correspondientes son proporcionales pero
sabemos que a g entre a d es igual a dos
tercios de esta forma a hg / edh también
debe ser dos tercios y por lo tanto hg
hg que es lo que acabamos de calcular
debe ser dos tercios de nueve y bueno
dos tercios de nueve vuelve a quedar
seis vale entonces esa es otra forma
entrar a hg bueno pero ese mismo
argumento lo vamos a utilizar para
encontrar fh solo que no lo vamos a
utilizar sobre f h sino sobre a h si
logramos determinar la longitud de h de
a h
entonces habremos terminado porque
bastaría restar estos 6 los 6 que van de
a a
efe vale entonces voy a marcar todo eso
por aquí aquí son 6 subimos para acá
entonces estos son 6 si encontramos a h
y le restamos 6 tendremos fh muy bien
entonces vamos a utilizar justo el
argumento que di para la forma
alternativa de encontrar hg observemos
que los triángulos a hg y ed son
semejantes porque tienen el ángulo recto
y el ángulo en común y entonces vamos a
aplicar este las razones de semejanza
que nos dan
vamos a utilizar las razones de
semejanza que tenemos y entonces tenemos
que h / a
no voy a poner por aquí a h / a
pero a emi de 12
es igual es igual a g
/ a de iguala a g g / a de pero nosotros
ya sabemos que a g / d es igual a dos
tercios estoy aquí es igual a dos
tercios verdad ese es el resultado que
probamos hacia algunos vídeos o bien
podemos usar que aje es 10 y a veces 15
y así multiplicando por 12 de ambos
lados nos queda que h es igual a 12 por
2 que es 24 entre 3 que es igual a 8 muy
bien entonces tenemos que a h es igual a
8 todo esto de acá es igual
8 muy bien pero conociendo a h podemos
restar a efe y con eso tenemos que f h
es igual a 25 efe hs 86 entonces f h es
igual a 2 y bueno con esto ya podemos
determinar el área de fhg simplemente el
área de fhg que la voy a poner por acá
el área de efe hg es igual es igual a un
medio de fh que es 2 por gh que 6
entonces el área que nos piden es igual
a 6 y listo con esto terminamos y con
esto resolvemos los tres problemas que
nos pide este ejercicio